in three 2 1
ex sh through the heart
and anyone but him you are literally the
last person on Earth I want to see slap
the out of you I really could and
I'm open to that in a safer environment
you've been a ghost no phone call no
text it's not like I didn't want to
apologize you don't have to explain
anything it was just a
flame so how have you
been God I hate that thumbs up sty
stuff I'm the director we're going to
set this man on fire you're a stunk guy
we need to keep it super profes profes
is my middle name you said your middle
name was
[Music]
danger how' we do
boss really really yeah that forget you
you never saw it the star of the movie
is missing you need to bring him back
save Jody's film You' got the love of
your life back I'm not the hero I'm just
the double not today you're
not Tom we already need you back on set
pal dead body on Ice he was so dead Gail
he was super
dead he has got himself involved with
some shady
people I had no choice I had to do
something Jason board
they were trying to kill
me and not in a fun way you can make it
you can make it you can't make it it's
too dangerous got be
stairs what happened to your face you
look terrible you look
amazing you fall down you get right back
up how far would you go for the one that
you
love engage your
core what are you doing later want to go
to a beach somewhere drink a spicy
margarit make some bad decisions
yes sh the heart and you're to
[Music]
blame